gérard jugnot bonsoir soir on va se
livrer une petite interview première
fois c'est bon vous voulez bien
la première baffe c'est pas la première
mais je viens et dont je me souviens
c'est quand j'avais fait une blague à
mon père qui venait de changer la
moquette il avait acheté une maquette
tout neuf c'est une grande grande
première et j'avais acheté une fausse
une fausse tâche d'encre une petite
bouteille d'encre et comme mon père vu
ça supprime terrible à mirabeau on
s'était pas c'était c'est resté très
secret la pâte sur une seule c'était sa
planète
elle n'a jamais su je crois quand même
le sait toujours quand et c'était
armoyan j'avais fait les plans de
toutain toute la côte sauvage
ça m'occupe et pour savoir si je
l'emmenais où j'aurais pu l'emmener au
moement l'embrasser en cachette sans que
ça paraisse donc j'avais fait toute une
topographie des lieux conçus jamais
servi première expérience sexuelle
c'était en tunisie en un club de
vacances qui n'était même pas
méditerranéen qu'une jeune fille que
j'ai pas forcément alors très envie mais
j'ai tellement tanné messieurs elle a
accepté gentiment premier pétard j'ai un
souvenir comment on fait fumer deux
tailles kermit et clavier on a été aux
états unis est en fait tiré là dessus
c'est une aire très forte
ça devait être un des premiers france
était un des derniers parce que c'est
une seconde à lui et c'était à saint
louis missouri doucement et d'un seul
coup j'ai vu tous les mecs sortir des
bosquets avec des fusils à canon scié et
plus henry henry est plurielle thèse non
c'est vrai ça et j'ai eu une vraie
panique donc n'ont pas montré sa
première expérience homosexuelle
on se tripoter dans les chiottes au lit
seul mais bon c'était pas très vraiment
moi sexuels s'étaient on a trop on
compterait défi et je mets pénétration
[Musique]
première paille à la paix n'était plus
moi plus importante c'est une paye de
figuration qui était à marquer artistes
de complément ça mon père est tombé à la
renverse arty de repaiement c'était pour
lui atroce considéré que ce n'était même
pas un artiste serti de complément aux
premiers millions d'anciens francs
je suis pas encore premier procès tu as
pensé que j'ai fait pour contre mon
sosie
parce que c'est une utilité mon image à
des fins commerciales qui me déplaisait
au revoir et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de linars dit tu es abonné vous y
mettez un peu de bleu